I'm an ecologist I work an organization
called eco health alliance we work in
wildlife conservation and human health
and do a lot of research into the
wildlife origins of human diseases and
how the interactions between humans and
animals can be improved both to protect
animals and reduce the risk of new
disease spillovers and that ranges from
field veterinary work to app development
work did a science in between you know
everything you know wildlife to
whiteboards and involves a lot of
collaboration and a lot of data sharing
with many different groups doing having
different skill sets working in
different paradigms around the world I
also as Jared said work with this
organization are open side that builds
tools to help people primarily using our
do more open and reproducible science so
we're really interested in making sure
that the research that people do gets
out into the world in a way that people
can reuse the analyses and the data that
originated in the lab and can go out
into other research groups into
businesses and so you can sort of have
that multiplicative effect of that
research do and so in both of these
contexts I'm really interested in how
data gets out and when you talk to
people who are in scientific
reproducibility who are librarians
there's sort of a series of best
practices
one has when you're sharing scientific
data that people want people to adhere
to you want to make sure that data is in
machine and human readable formats so it
can be future proof your CSV ES and TSVs
your xml and json x' all those formats
they can be parsed by lots of different
languages they probably part be able to
be parsed by future languages if people
don't know that you can open it up and
inspect it and see what the problems are
that's thought of best practice and you
want to put those in long-term
scientific library archives that have a
lifespan beyond you know the current
grant cycle the current business model
people who have figured out how to do
this sort of library level archiving to
make sure that we can have things
available you know after your project
wraps up you want standardized metadata
so data can talk to
each other so they can link to each
other so people can use that information
to understand what is in the data set
they're looking at and you need
documentation of all of that now one of
the things we do a lot in the our
community is package data into our
packages right and it's kind of funny
when you put it data into an r package
that doesn't necessarily work with this
paradigm usually the data is in the RDS
and RDA formats which are binary and not
inspectable and specific to a language
and even though our manual tells you it
could change from version to version so
it may not be future proof github and
cran which is where we put these
packages are great but they're not
necessarily built for a long-term
archiving at the scale that libraries
and scientific repositories are and when
it comes to metadata and documentation
that's possible but you may or may not
you know do that because it's not
enforced in the places that packages are
put nonetheless it is something we do a
lot so this is from a little project we
did at the ARB inside conference last
year where we were looking at how people
use our packages to transfer data and
the first thing that pops out is that we
do it a great deal almost half of the
packages on cran distribute a dataset in
some way now a lot of the times that
data set is an example data set for a
statistical method or for the for a
function that is packaged in the library
but lots of those data sets are here's
in our package for associating with a
book or an hour package associated with
a scientific paper or something else
where people you know want that data to
get into the hands of people but it
doesn't meet those requirements so why
do we do it well there's a bunch of
advantages of having a data in the
package and the first is you get to
hijack the package distribution and
storage infrastructure cran and github
the places we host package are very
central very visible a lot less
fragmented than actually the scientific
data repository world and so you have a
lot of visibility by putting something
up there secondarily you have a local
infrastructure if your packages on your
computer there's a pack
library which can act as a data library
which means you can have a place where
you have a single copy of the data that
is shareable across projects you're not
going to fragment and have different
versions of the data across your machine
if it's available in a package so that's
great
you get to take advantage of the binary
format so they exist there for a reason
they're fast to load they're fast to
save they can handle lots of different
types of data structures and so that's
one reason to do it and then when you
build a package around data you can
facilitate the anticipated workflows
around that data you have dedi or
serving you have assumptions and ideas
of how people are going to use it and
you can facilitate those things by
building functions in to have certain
types of graphing of that data or
certain types of processing of that data
to help people along and the linking of
that software and data you know makes
that an analysis process easier if you
can anticipate what the analysis process
is and then you can use the
documentation system which is built
right into your analysis environment
your your R console your our Studio
server so you can document that data
right next to where you're working with
that data and people can use it so you
have all of these advantages but there
are a bunch of different ways you can
package data in R into an R package that
vary in the degree of their trade-offs
with these best practices with for
scientific archival and for different
types of workflows and so I'm going to
talk about three and then kind of
advocate for one so first we have data
in packages themselves which is what
I've been talking about so far generally
this is going to be small data if you're
distributing through cran cran has a
five mega byte limit on the packages
themselves which means you're bid are
going to be even smaller than that it's
generally going to be fixed these
systems are not designed for rapid
iteration of the packages on those on
those platforms and so you're not really
going to be having data that changes on
a really regular basis packaged up it's
usually going to be at the end of a
study you put it there you set it up and
that limitation is imposed by the
hosting services by these community
groups that are managing
kranj or another package distribution
like bioconductor like our own and our
open sai and for that reason the
datasets really are limited so you
they're good for teachings datasets
they're good for demonstrations for your
packages but there's a lot you can't
distribute it through the normal wrap
the data in the package directly next
you have data API wrappers and this is
becoming a very common pattern for
people to use across all sorts of
disciplines and all sorts of businesses
rather than putting your data in a
package you put your data online on a
server that can serve it via a web api
and then one builds a package around
those api's in order to pull them down
and so people can query that API
directly pull some subset of that data
or some query of that data and it has
some great advantages the size can be
unlimited it's only limited by the
server infrastructure that's out there
which means you could have server
structures that involve many machines
across many databases in many places you
know you can have live changes those
servers are tied to other events other
web services things are changing minute
to minute you can make that query
it'll differ a minute to minute you're
only limited by your server capacity
your systems and white types of queries
you can send and what's built into the
API endpoints you design so that works
well for this sort of targeted querying
for asking a question of a big data set
where you can send that question up but
it's not as good for analyzing data and
mass because you have to move that data
every time you make a call and for a lot
of analyses maybe the query doesn't have
the ability to do that at the server
level or you have big computational
demands and if you're just trying to
distribute these data sets to a lot of
people you may not be able to manage a
server and have that infrastructure for
them that's computational nonetheless we
build a lot of data API wrappers at our
open SCI biological ecological
geological chemical all sorts of
scientific databases exist out there and
common data repositories and we make a
project of connecting
with these of our via our packages that
wrap these api's you can grab lots of
things we work in labor and economic
data government social government social
data it's it's a whole spectrum and this
is just like a small small screen shot
of a very long webpage that we have and
this is sort of our bread and butter
nonetheless I think what a pattern that
we're using more and that I like more
and more is the idea of data sync where
we have a limitation of local hard disk
size which is often adequate for a lot
of the things that we want to do so
there's there are data sets which we
serve in a static fashion on a remote
source and they're all of the our
package is to sync that remote source to
your own computer and update it on some
kind of regular basis so you're not
working with live data minute to minute
changes but you can deal with version
changes across data sets as you have
regular releases on weekly or monthly or
annual basis and that's really limited
by your local analyst resources what can
fit on a hard disk but as long as you
have that you can analyze all of that
data at once and you're doing sort of
big global level analyses which is a lot
of what we do that's the limiting factor
and we want to be able to capture all of
the data together so I really like this
pattern it's in the like megabyte to
multi-gigabyte data scale now that
doesn't work for everything if you have
click data clicked it ends up in two
terabytes and petabytes and who knows
but in my case if a data point is not a
click but a person in a tie vex suit in
a forest all night catching a bat and
swapping its anus with a q-tip and that
gets us one one data point when we get
to megabytes and gigabytes were really
doing well you know it works well for
this regular but not live updates and so
we can have version data which means
here's an analysis at version 1 enough
version 2 we have the speed and
versatility of having the data locally
when we work on it and we can facilitate
by wrapping this process in a package
that has functions and documents for
working for specific kinds of data so
how does a package like this work and
what tools do you use to build it well
the core that we've been using recently
is a package
called datastore by a guy named rich
Fitzjohn who's also part of the our open
side developers collective and datastore
is designed to manage this data sync
process between remote and local sources
and dealing with versioning so the thing
you get with datastore is the creation
of a data library in addition to having
a package library you have a data
library and the are up doors and store
packages are what enable us to do that
and have it work agnostically across
different across different operating
systems sort of and keep things
efficiently stored if so we keep the
versions that we need and not the
versions but we don't its able to deal
with essentially any file type because
you provide it with the load functions
you want for your data when you're
building a package it'll auto generate
the code for the core functions you need
in order to use the function to use this
package which is great its default
setting is to use github releases as our
versioning mechanism so you attach data
to get hub releases which let you attach
data of up to two data files of up to
two gigabytes size per version but
there's potential for other backends in
the package so we're working on making
it connect with scientific repositories
like Xen odo or figshare
or the open Open Science framework which
also enabled these sort of storage of
large versioned objects the other thing
we really like to use is taking
advantage of good file types in order to
speed up the iterative data process so
you can use you know the sort of optimal
archival CSVs and Jason's and xml's
but often because we have this sync and
load process when people are working
with the data we want to make sure the
data transfer is fast and the loading
process and fast so we want fast losed
formats and good compression I really
like FST for tabular data there's a lot
of good options out there for fast on
disk tabular data and are at this point
between feathers and FF and all of these
things FST is a great one it works
really
and taking advantage of local
multi-threading and the thing that I
like a lot is it gets great compression
without a lot of loss of load or right
times and so you're able to you know
load multi-millionaire of data frames in
you know a matter of seconds it performs
at least as well as most of the options
out there and one of the nice things is
you can store data and work with it on
disk without loading to memory there's
an experiment spera mental package by
I'm getting at his name room carol
muller to use a deep liar pipeline with
these files you have the deep liar
back-end just like it works with an SQL
database it can work with FST files so
an example of this so we built a package
for ascites sides-- is the Convention on
International trade of endangered
species we use this data a great deal to
understand the flow of wildlife across
the world
the organization has more than 40 years
of data of essentially every wildlife
trade between treaty countries that has
occurred but they didn't have a bulk way
to export it we needed to use it in bulk
so we built a package that that uses
these and we've just put up a first
version of it so we have our you know
version one of the data but it'll update
as we have new submissions decide ease
it updates on the order of months when
countries submit their trade data so
it's not a minute-to-minute thing but
its version and that's important for us
and essentially how it works is you just
have a date a function to call the data
which is site e's data if it's not
currently available in your library
it'll download that highly compressed
binary off of the repository in this
case github and you can specify the
version you want to load so that'll load
up it moves relatively fast but once you
have done that a first-time 1.0 is
cached on your computer and so when you
call it again it'll load up immediately
and so we have quick access to in this
case two million rows of data that is
easy to work with across projects anyone
can just add this function in and you
don't have to have you know
fragmentation of the datasets across
different things are working with
sometimes you don't have control of the
upstream component of your data so what
we often do is have a data design
pattern where we have pull from an API
but sync to a local database that we
maintain so there's an SQLite database
in our data library and for different
packages that in this case work with
taxonomic data or infectious disease
surveillance data we sync that data down
into local database you can work on it
and you just run sort of a single let's
download the current database function
it'll pull it down sync your look sync
what you have locally and you can work
with it then with the taxonomic database
we actually built originally an API
package to do the calls but because of
the slowness of that access we moved to
this design and so we actually have two
packages they have the exact same code
API so if in this case we're making a
call of in this case we're doing a
taxonomic lookup at the NCBI database
you know you can run it with an API call
it'll take a couple of seconds to pull
down the data of making HTTP requests or
you can do it with the version of the
package that maintains a local database
and what we pull up is 10 times faster
and actually scales much better too many
requests because you can vectorize the
requests locally but not to the API
other sort of helpers we use in packages
like this is giving a package status so
when you load up your package we show
the status of the local databases which
tables you have available what you've
downloaded when you've downloaded what
you can update and so this is helpful
it's especially helpful for our case
where the table availability depends on
one security permissions across the
shared project so maybe you'll have some
data and not others it shows what's
available when you load it up which is
helpful for an analyst one of the other
patterns we've been using across these
data access packages is in making
metadata useful so a lot of times when
there's a big data set available in a
public repository there'll be a code
book or a metadata sheet along with
it that has something like you know
descriptions of the codes that are there
the units that are available for the
columns the descriptions necessary and
it's often in a document like this a PDF
or a doc and it's there for good reason
because they expect people to read it
with their eyes they want people to be
able to scan it and look something up
but then you don't have the ability to
work with it in a computational way for
instance to link codes and descriptions
for visualizations so for the case of
societies and some other projects that
we've worked on in this case we use a
package called tabular the wraps the
tabula PDF library which can extract
that data into a structured tidy data
frame and so we every time we download
this PDF data it becomes tidy data so
you can work with that data but then
there's the reverse problem this tidy
data you know this data frame you know
contains a lot of values and you want to
be able to scan it quickly to search it
to use to use it for a lookup purposes
and so we had this approach where while
we have the data itself available within
a package we also build it into the help
files as an HTML widget so if you search
for help about the metadata of a package
it will pop up an HTML help file which
has a searchable data table you know a
lot of people don't realize that our
help system is capable of very rich HTML
markup you can have images you can have
forms you can have all sorts of things
you would have on a web page you know it
takes some rube goldberg
because you've got you know HTML and
JavaScript inside our documentation
files inside her oxygen comments and
there's a lot of escaping and fixing you
have to do but we implemented inside
ease I'm hoping to wrap it into sort of
a helper package for this purpose too
and then finally we provide analysts
with breadcrumbs so one of the things we
implement across things is print
functions that flag conditions in the
data that might be important for
instance if there are field notes
associated with the fields and the
subsets you pull up we show those flags
so that people know look at the notes or
they might show
there are duplicate fields in this data
and so that helps people as they're
exploring data but since it's only
involved in the interactive print
methods when you actually implement a
data pipeline you don't have the
performance hit of doing those lookups
and checks every time you print but it
helps people understand the data as they
get so in some if we're designing data
packages we have choices we can store
the data we can query the data or we can
sync the data and that choice really
depends on your data scale and your time
weight of your turnover
I think sync syncing version data is
something that is very useful and is
useful at the scale of data that a lot
of people work at it's helped with these
efficient formats like your feathers and
your FS T's and moving an SQLite
database back and forth and then when
you do that you can build rich
documentation and you can build
guideposts for your analysts along the
way
and all of these things help us sort of
minimize the trade-offs we have with
sort of archival storage problems and I
think as we develop a few more of these
tools we'll be able to connect with the
scientific backends with all of the
efficiencies that we get with these API
and syncing approaches so that's it
thank you very much
thank you
you